this is share your world the show where
we share stories
and reflect on our own cultural
backgrounds so that we can learn about
each other's worlds from home
in this episode we're talking about all
things music
theater and dance from traditional
performances to iconic instruments and
more
i've always been interested in music
theater and dance even as a child
last year was my first trip to armenia
in yerevan
and it was so close to a place that we
visited called the magarian carpet
factory where
they weave carpets but they also
integrate everything from the armenian
culture for visitors to see
so they have traditional garb and music
and dance and food
when i went they put on like a little
performance for us with
uh traditional music and we have an
instrument
called duduk and it's made out of the
apricot
wood it's such a beautiful sound and i
think it was just
an overwhelming experience being in
armenia and hearing that sound that i
grew up listening to and
that and music i grew up dancing to
because i am a ball of emotions today
really
so one of my favorite instruments in
europa culture is the talking drum
and the really cool part about the
talking drum is that
it mimics human speech it
literally sounds like someone singing or
someone talking
i believe it's one of the only
instruments that has not been able to be
translated to like midi sounds or to be
synthesized
when i went home for the first time when
i was 17
i got to see the talking drum used and
it was just very powerful
to like experience it in real life
on the continent in nigeria i just love
it
so last summer i was able to go visit my
parents in korea
they've always wanted me to go to the
kyongbokkong palace it's majestic it's
architecturally really strong and sturdy
and there's a changing of the guard
ceremony every morning and
what you can do is on the outskirts of
the palace you can go
rent a hamburg which is a traditional
korean outfit for three hours and then
you get to walk the palace and kind of
you know feel like what it must have
been like back then
so it's kind of like an immersive
theater experience and it's wonderful to
see
everybody dressed in costume i think i
was there at that palace i'm pretty sure
it's the same palace
yeah it's a pretty famous palace i kind
of like where everyone goes when you
visit korea
so when i was visiting korea i stayed at
the westin chosen which is really close
and easy to get to to kyongbokung palace
and i mean the rooms are spacious the
amenities the lobby's gorgeous and it's
just so nice to just
be a tourist all day and then come back
to kind of luxurious hotel settings and
just like
rest relax rejuvenate and then go back
out and just you know
see the rest of seoul so for uh my dance
for cambodian dance
um it used to be performed in front of
like kings and queens and royalty where
people would
um be dressed in in similar outfits to
like the cambodian wedding outfits but
they would be
like in golds with like brackets and
with crowns
but they would do special hand movements
so there's hand movements that correlate
with the dance and
the hand movements like mean something
so there's definitely a lot of
movement and storytelling and it's slow
like watching it like a ballet where you
can actually see the story which is a
lot about like
life and balance and i was never
able to like get it like perfectly
because just like it's really technical
and you have to bend your fingers and
like they practice
betting their fingers as a kid so they
like
they can like bend it all the way back
like i don't know if you can try it but
it's it's really intense
yeah like it gets it tells the story so
switzerland is very much
known for the alporn or in swiss it's
called alpol
which is basically the same um and it's
used or used to be used
um back in the day in the alps in the
swiss alps where you know they have cows
and sheep
and they used a horn to call them so
that they would come all back together
and go back to the stables at night
and it doesn't have any buttons or any
strings or any openings it's just a
solid
wooden corn and i've never played it
myself but i know you caroline have
but i know it's very difficult to play
it that was difficult but after
like practicing it's like once you get
it you just don't want to stop
[Music]
[Applause]
debbie you have to do it you have to do
it the next time you go
yes i want to next time whenever i can
go back home
it's going to be on my list for sure i
actually want to go to switzerland
uh i want to go to all of your countries
but switzerland i have ties to somewhat
because
my mom is half swiss my mom is half
nigerian
yeah so she she tells me stories all the
time of like how she would go there for
um holiday when she was young but i've
never been able to go
so hearing all of your stories i'm like
yes have to get there and if you're like
us i know you can't wait until we can
travel again to experience
these and other music theater and dance
performances in person
[Music]
you